ثعلوب الحرامي
صَعَدَ الثَّعْلُوبُ المَكَّارْ
وَتَسَلَّقَ إحْدَىْ الأَشْجَارْ
كَي يَسْرِقْ بَيْتَ العُصْفُورِ
فِي غَفْلَةْ ذَاكَ الغَدَّارْ
جَذَبَ الثَّعَلبُ قِفْلَ البَابْ
حَاوَلَ تَكْسِيرَ الأَخْشَابْ
وَلِيَدْخُلَ دَفَعَ النَافِذَةَ
هَذَا لَيْسَ مِنَ الآَدَابْ
سَمِعَتْ أَفْرَاخُ العُصْفُورْ
بِالخَارِجِ مَا كَانَ يَدُورْ
كان عِنْدَ البَابِ حَرَامِي
جَاءَ لَسَرِقَتِنَا المَغْرُورْ
وَضَعُوا خَلْفَ البَابِ أَرِيكَةْ
وَسَرِيراً يَصْعُبُ تَحْرَيكَهْ
كُرْسِي جِدُّو وَالمِقْلاَةْ
وأَلْعَابَ البيبى المَفْكُوكَةْ
حَالًا سَنُلَقِّنُ ثَعْلوُبْ
دَرْسًا يَجَعَلُه المَغْلُوبْ
وَسَنَطْلُبُ لِلِّصِّ الشُّرْطَةْ
نَعْرِفُ مَا الرَّقَمُ المَطْلُوبْ
ثعلوب الحرامي
سَكَبُوا عَلَيْهِ دَلْوَ طِلاَءْ
مِنْ نَافِذَةٍ فِي العَلْيَاءْ
وَفَطِيِرَةَ مَامَا بِالتُّوتْ
فَتَعَثَّرَ وَهَوَىْ فِي المَاءْ
سَقَطَ اللِّصُّ مِنَ الأَغْصَانْ
مُبْتَلًّا يَبْكِى وَمُهَانْ
قَالَ الشُّرْطِي هَذَا جَزَاؤُكْ
وَضَعُوهُ خَلْفَ القُضْبَانْ